and my ex-wife lulu or know his her
daughter's
is talking to her telling her uh that
there's
there's a kid in the gym that uh
knows that has family in mexico that
kills people and chops people up for
money
and my ex-wife responds by oh we might
be able to use them
what the [ __ ] exactly and mundo just
happened to walk by and he was like
you know the same thing basically like
what yeah yeah
so you know my cousin
so uh so he he tells he he's like whoa
whoa whoa
you know he kind of snapped him because
he already knew that me and her were
going through a terrible
you know very tough divorce and he goes
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
we have a very special special guest
here not chris cause he's been on here
multiple times
but we got chris's pops on this podcast
with chris
after he just lost the boxing match
[Applause]
[Laughter]
chris how would you like to talk about
your loss
that's how you're going off straight up
huh i would like to say that it wasn't
an official uh sanctioned
fight it was not it doesn't go on a
record yeah so what i like to say is uh
it was a fun night
the funniest thing about chris is he
doesn't take loss very well
even if it wasn't like a sanction for
this is a new this is a new uh
thing for you good to see you with me
huh yeah you did not think lost very
well at all man like it's hard on you
it is not even a real loss because it
was a friendly it was a friendly
like probably a little more firmer than
regular sparring yeah no no i definitely
i mean
listen they they they also they
obviously you know decide a winner so
obviously yeah i took a
i took the l you know i mean that that
uh pack got it
uh pat got the less of me
nah but uh no pat did his thing man i
think i think
most importantly man i i definitely uh
uh wasn't
as prepared as i should have been and uh
it showed that's what that's basically
all it was
why did you prepare huh we're just kind
of just having fun with it or like well
no
um whenever i when we heard about it
like
a month prior and then i flew to houston
and um i also have been working on
projects in houston
and then uh my buddy and i ended up
coming across
a dope dp and we just started like we
just decided to crank out like four
sketches
and i got so into it that i wasn't
putting time aside to train i was just
like
you know when i when i had time to run i
ran you know what i mean and i would
just run
because that's my dad's whole thing was
like just make sure you run you know and
my dad
also you know you know if it ain't if it
ain't a professional boxing thing or
even amateur boxing my dad just kind of
sees it as like
no i took it as you know when you told
me about that you know i thought it was
just going to be like a friendly
you know comedians getting together
mm-hmm and doing the sparks
a little close to your face yeah i
thought there was going to be like a
comedians getting together
doing some kind of you know charity
events something like that so i didn't
i didn't take it very seriously because
you know i've been around boxing all my
life and i know when it's something that
is serious that is
sanctioned and is and i was worried
about that too i kept asking chris
what's the rules what you know what kind
of stuff is this i've never heard
anything like this but it turned out to
be a pretty good
you know little squabble there yeah yeah
so
hey hey hey exactly
you know ain't nothing against the kid
yeah yeah
yeah nothing against pat the kid you
know the kid you know he
he put the work in put the work out and
unfortunately chris
you can't make no excuses in boxing
because i've been around boxes of my
life i said maybe this is what you want
to do
you know when so what what at what age
did you start training chris chris
started when he was about seven
oh [ __ ] yeah he had a lot of fights
chris has a lot of fights on his belt
you know yeah
and when i see him being sloppy in the
ring i'm like i'm like nah that's nice i
disown your ass like
yeah yeah i saw this guy giving you the
finger in the corner he's like
[ __ ] this guy hey you know after the
second round i was really thinking about
let me throw in the timeline
[Applause]
there's some heavy breathing going on
there yeah that's what that's what it
was man
it was literally like uh uh my cousin
has saw it from the live i
i had a few i had uh somebody helping me
from the gym
um she was really nice of like you know
handling my live and
so i have people from my followers
checking it out and stuff and
my cousin was like bro it looked like
you were you were trying to bust out old
school moves of what you
do but you were just delayed you know
like just awesome
yeah just being like slow like every
every like any like fly move i was
trying to do
it was slow because of how like how
tired i was and it was just kind of just
like
you know try to hit him but you know
what that happens to a typical fighter
that hasn't fought a long time with a
fighter that's
you know that's like saying me trying to
get back in the ring my mind
my mind's sharp you know boxing shot
like i know physically
yeah physically i'm not gonna do it
because my body's not just gonna be able
to react
hard work would be telling every day and
now that was a pure example of that
yesterday
hard work that was a pure example of
that like
hard work would be telling you all day i
can't take nothing away from pat
i'm just myself myself bro i'm kind of
just like pat come on bro let's get back
in it man
you know what i mean like let's run it
back bro like you know what i mean like
like that he does in my thing pat
doesn't even have to
god doesn't have to do this he doesn't
have to do a rematch he could just like
take the dub and he's like eating him up
he's leading you up
yeah man you know yeah and and
you know yeah and the thing is is like
you know it really it
it was more to me because you know my
dad's in my corner yeah you know
the nostalgic two or five thousand miles
to get over here
yeah when you guys when when he started
boxing at seven right
um for you is it hard for you to coach
uh your your son because you also you
also have like a personal connection
with you
oh yeah definitely you know what as a
father figure you know as a father
training his son i don't care who it is
because i talk to a lot of fathers a lot
of times
fathers live through their kids and
you'll see
in you sport or sports yeah a lot of
times you see fathers trying to live
through their kids and that's that
wasn't me
i didn't want him to box i didn't want
oh yeah i didn't want my kids to box
because i know the kind of sport boxing
is how grueling
it is you know the training regimen you
know the physical mental the traveling
the
ups and downs i love it and all that
stuff that i went through i didn't want
him to go through you know but uh
he the way chris started he when he was
little i had a
bag in my you know i had a little
workout deal in my in my
in my garage and he would sit there and
watch me you know you know hit the bags
and everything
and also and this kid just picked it up
naturally just you know and then i
and at that time i had a uh i trained
fighters amateur boxers
and uh every time we went to a boxing
show chris was like maybe five i think
before that if i was six
and he would get in the ring before you
know before the show start he would just
get in the ring and he would just start
shadow boxing and
and doing it everybody was like who's
this little boy
so even even before he started competing
uh because he can't compete in amateurs
till it but you're about eight
so even before he was his first fight
everybody knew who he was you know
in the houston area because he every
time we had a boxing show and i had
boxers
competing he would get in the ring and
you know and boxing and show out and
everything
you know so it was pretty cool you know
but yeah but from
in my heart i didn't want chris the box
i don't you know it's it's something
that
it uh it hurts me to see my kid
you know get punched go through all that
and and then
if it doesn't go his way you know it's
just like i take all
the blame i feel like you know i i am
down you know but it's nothing like that
you know
yeah yeah yeah you got to move on so for
you like when you when you
when you were getting coached by your
dad did you ever have thoughts of like
because i
always wondered too with like well habib
just won right
today his father passed away right yeah
and there's like this this interesting
bond and balance that i think like
parent and coach has right
like was it hard for you to to take
instruction from your dad also as a
coach and as a father
no i thought i thought um well maybe i
think i think sometimes like you know
there there will be times where
you know uh when when we were when we
were actually competing and i was
younger and um
we were doing the real thing when he
when we were doing the pads and stuff
like there would be sometimes where i
kind of be bothering like you know
oh no like like talking back basically
yeah i would talk back to him sometimes
which you know you wouldn't talk back to
your coach
you know but i was talking back to him
you know you know well i mean you
shouldn't even talk back to your dad
either but
you know just kind of like this you know
father-son father-son type of thing so
there was that
um but honestly man like i didn't like
it if when he wasn't training me
like when there were when there were
times where you know we had to go fight
out of the city and like my dad couldn't
make it and stuff he would have like
another coach that like we were we were
together we had like our team
and another dad would take us and i did
not like
my dad not being in my corner you know
what i mean so for me
uh i didn't want i didn't want anybody
in my corner other than my dad
so even with this with this show i was
like yo pops like you try to work my
corner
and at first he was kind of just like
son like i don't want
like he didn't know what this kind of
thing was so he was like
if it's going to be on some like
underground fight club stuff
i don't want to be a part of nothing
like that and i'm like yo pops i need
you man
i was almost like how come you don't
want me man
no but yeah seriously i i thought it was
going to be some kind of you know i
don't play that you know i'm very
professional
and about boxing uh something that i've
done for a long time and i know the
inside out and i know all the you know
the regulations and
and i don't get involved in any kind of
underground kind of boxing any kind of
uh you know thing that
where somebody gets hurt in the ring
because it's very serious
boxing even when you're messing around
even in the sparring session you can get
hurt
having a hemorrhage or something happen
and somebody's got to be liable for that
you know
and whoever's involved in that ring and
if i'm involved in and i'm licensed or
you know whatever
i mean they can come up to me too you
know so yeah i don't play with any all
that
on the ground boxing i just don't uh so
i just want to make sure and you know
everything's all legit well boxing in
the last year has been kind of crazy
especially with the in-ring deaths
recently yeah uh well i think it's like
two or three just in the past year or so
it can happen at any time you know and
and people understand
you know you could you can a lot of
these fighters go you know
they could be sparring and and they can
get hurt in in the gym
because you know coaches are paying
attention for whatever reason they can
get hurt
you know have a hemorrhage and that you
know and they just
go home with a headache or whatever they
don't know they don't go to the doctor
they don't they don't follow up with
with the pain and and they come back and
a couple days later start sparring or
they might have a fight
and you know you get hit the wrong way
you then you're done
that's kind of crazy i can understand
why it was hard for you to see
did you were you the one that wanted to
stop boxing or did you want him to stop
boxing first
i think you know what happened it was in
it wasn't chris's fault it was more of a
when his mother and i got divorced you
know i kind of went my way
and he went his way with his mother well
you know his mother had
had the uh you know guardianship with
the kids
so then it was hard for me to to see him
like we were seeing before
yeah and the training and then you know
the traveling and all that
yeah all the circumstances just started
adding up and like it just like started
building a building and then gradually
it just started fading
um you know there were times where like
i would be crying because i just want to
get to the gym like i'm just telling my
mom or telling my dad too because there
we
you know there were times where you know
my parents you know during
during that whole divorce thing you know
it was it was ugly and stuff like that
and there would be times where i would
kind of hold it as like an
ultimatum of like yo like there were
times where i'd be like yo pause i'm
gonna quit boxing man if if this whole
like thing keeps
you know being ugly yeah and then there
were times where i'm at home and i'm
like yo mom i gotta i gotta i gotta keep
going to the gym or like and it was just
it was so many uh
things and then whenever i got to high
school um
that's where it really that's where it
was like i had a few fights maybe as
a freshman those were like my last few
fights whatever but then
once i became a a junior i started
acting i was like i got into theater and
stuff and then
i had because i never did anything after
school like because
i had to go to the gym after school but
um once i got into theater then i
started rehearsing and stuff and then my
pops like
went to go well how to how to play and
he saw me perform for the for the first
time as far as like acting and stuff
like that my dad was like
i didn't remember i was like you you
know i remember coming to you when he
came up to me with that
i'm going i'm an actor i said yo what
yeah i'm an actor that's when you did
shakespeare
yeah and i went to go see him my first
question is like how can you remember
all those lines yeah you had a you had a
blonde you can't remember your combos in
the ring
him practicing he had like a little
thing it was like a thing of a book like
this to remember
and he knew everybody's lines you know
he's like he had said that i gotta
remember everybody just to be on you
know on time i was like
that's crazy but i was amazed you know
the first time i saw him was like that's
my son out there
and then when he was a senior he won you
guys won the
the state championship right where did
that what we got we got to the states
but we ended up getting
second place no but you when you're
senior you got second place oh no as a
senior i
i mean no as a senior i got we got to
regionals as my junior we got to states
but
i got uh like i want i want a best actor
that's what you're talking about
do you think like i i always look at
this from like uh from like a hindsight
because
it's 20 20 for me it's interesting how
like uh you know when you were going
through the divorce with you with your
with your ex-wife
and that caused like a break in a rift
in your training like do you think that
you still would have gravitated towards
active it wasn't for that break
um i don't know i don't know to be
honest with you
but you know because there was a point
where i was living with my dad because
of
the way the school district was uh my
dad lived
near the school that i still wanted to
go to and so
um i ended up you know living with my
dad for a little bit
and and that even even with that like we
we trained and stuff like that i think
that was like my eighth grade year and
uh
we trained and he he also was uh you
know picking up his boxing business as
well
and um there was also like you know i
you know we we've kind of above head
butt heads about it but like
he had his uh uh fighters as well and
you know he he also because i think i
think when
whenever you know my parents split stuff
and he's doing his own thing
he end up building a business in boxing
and excuse me
uh building a business boxing and uh
getting fighters and then having pro
fighters and then
also like uh like uh
what is it amateur fighters that were
like on the way to be a pro like and
we were on the same like squad like man
like kids that i grew up with like you
know casey
marshall uh uh nico like all these all
these guys that
you know to me i'm thinking like i'm at
their level
if not better that's how i'm that's how
i'm treating it you know what i mean
and that's how i'm always going to treat
it and you know i'm seeing them from
from hindsight and they're on tv and you
know
homie has like you know getting these
nationals winning these national
competition stuff and i'm over here my
mom's like
well it's been nice you know i'm like
damn and i you know i used to call my
power yo
how come you don't train me like that
man you don't train me like that and it
was it was a it was a whole thing man
and then like we finally had a
heart-to-heart maybe about a couple
years ago
like we finally sat down and my dad was
kind of just like
because i i mean this happens every year
bro and i've talked to you about it too
but my dad finally was just like man
he gave he said kind of what he was
saying just now like i i just didn't
want
you know it's easy to tell a fighter
who's like who comes back to the corner
cut up blood coming out nose and all
just looking
ugly in the corner and still telling
like you know all right come on
get out there but for me what he was
telling me he was like yo
it's just like hard to just be looking
at my son like that and
you know but to me i'm like you saying
i'm a [ __ ] like you think i'm gonna
come back to the corner
and then we'll come back to the corner
cut up like you know what i mean like
but i mean interestingly enough because
well because of the lomachenko and the
teo female fight right you saw the
relationship that theo female had with
his father
yeah his father treated well he was
crying in that interview if you saw that
and you could see teofimo
wants his father just to be a father so
that that there's
you know there's two sides to that coin
right where you have the dad coach
or he's more coached than he is father
and you can see by his behavior how he
talks to a son
and how teo fimo was talking about his
dad in the interview
it's more like he was like yeah i just
you know i just want my dad to be a dad
and he never got that but he could look
at his son like he's a fighter like go
in there make these adjustments get hit
again do it over and over and over
yeah but there's but you could see that
there's a trade-off like i think that's
the hard part
yeah and you know on the same topic as
i've seen i've seen a lot of uh
coaches that have a coach father you
know their their kids their sons
or daughters and like i said earlier
they try to they're trying to live
their through their kids you know
something that they couldn't do when
they were young
and a lot of them have never even fought
one round in their lives
amateur professionally and
and when i see that that's like okay
sometimes in the back of myself you know
just because you didn't do it
now you want your son or daughter to do
it and when they don't do it
i see him in the corner yelling at them
i see him outside the ring
you know every time i've seen the key a
father slap the crap out of his son
because they didn't do good in the ring
and i'm thinking how many times how many
times how many fights did you have
yeah how many times you know were you in
the ring you don't know what the kid
goes through and i know what i went
through
win or lose whatever happened but you
know i'm not the type of kid i mean a
father that's going to get to her son
embarrass him in front of the of of of
of a crowd or you know just because he's
not as good as what you think you know
he should be
because there's very very small
percentage of kids of sons or daughters
that make it in
in in the sport of boxing you know with
that that you know
father father son trainer i mean i can
look at the one of the best ones was
tutor trinidad and his father
you know they went they went to another
level then these guys went you know
but then there were some you know look
at trent look at de la hoya and his dad
you know they kind of split up yeah
it's hard you know it's hard to to train
your son
or daughter at that level and see i can
talk to a fighter
a different way that i can talk to my
son because this is
you know when i talk to my son he comes
back to the corner sometimes he gets
personal from the heart
yeah you know and and i see sometimes
when when fathers talk to their sons on
tv or whatever i watch a fight
when they're talking to a fight to the
as a son they talk to them
differently now when i'm talking to a
fighter and you know that i'm training
that it's just it's just a different
type of
you know feeling you know and that
sometimes gets in the way
of man i don't you know i've seen some
guys get hit
like cold [ __ ] knocked the bleep out
yeah
and i was one of my son to do that this
podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha not all matcha is curated and
created the same and junebe matcha
stands out above the rest
if your matcha isn't a beautiful shade
of green and doesn't have an earthy
smooth taste then you are definitely not
having junebe
matcha is not supposed to be bitter the
caffeine boosts and health benefits you
get from it are the best no caffeine
jitters and loaded
with a bunch of antioxidants to get 10
off your first
order of tins and packets go to
junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain once again that's 10 off
your first order of tins and packets go
to junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain so you guys were talking
about like a specific story
which you guys did on all deaf what's
that story about
um well my dad really it's my dad's
story it's um
my dad got into a little sticky
situation
uh with his uh second wife not my mom i
always have to clear that out because
some people come to me and be like yo
you know hey i don't know what your mom
i'm like
what about my mom bro it's a little
weird that you know coming to somebody
about that like yeah
like your mom i'm like no it wasn't my
mom man that was my second the second
wife yeah second second marriage
um uh so i said second wife like you
married
two two women my second mom
uh but yeah no um
my dad my dad got into a whole uh
situation man when
in the second marriage it ended up
ending uh pretty bad but they were going
through a divorce but
she wanted to end the divorce a little
quicker and get a little uh
money off of it so she tried uh um
uh doing some dirty stuff to my dad and
uh
tried having him murdered uh to get what
she had to yeah bro yeah
you alluded to like some kind of weird
[ __ ] i didn't know it was a murder for
[ __ ] hire yeah yeah yeah bro no
no he uh uh it was a it was a whole
thing bro because
you know she was talking to some people
and uh in mexico and
and uh you know it was over her i mean
i'll let my dad dive into it i just kind
of want to get a little
uh you know uh basically the prologue
but uh
but yeah man it ended up being a whole
thing man it was all
it was all over houston and uh the the
news out there and then like
it like some uh random interview in
london and then it popped off bro
worldwide japan got it uh uh uk
it came back to the u.s and then that's
when all dev uh um
well def also got it like firsthand
because i was also working at all dev
but um you know other networks hbo 48
hours dateline
like ended up being a whole thing oh my
god okay
we gotta start from the beginning yeah
how did you meet your second wife
yeah uh well i at the time i had been
divorced
about 10 years from chris's mom my first
wife we had three kids together three
wonderful kids you know my oldest son
mitchell
chris is the middle son and then me as
my youngest
and at the time i was very involved with
boxing i had been
traveling a lot with the boxing and
training
uh people i mean young young young cats
and uh so one evening in 2009 i think it
was
in 2009 i went out for you know i was
just hanging out just feel like going
out for
for a drink so i went out and and and
to a mexican restaurant in the suburbs
of houston
and this restaurant turns into a bar
like after after 10
so when you know and they play salsa
music and you know i love salsa so i
went in there
looking sharp you know and when i walked
in i saw this
the the dancer was packed and i saw this
one lady dancing i was like oh man she
looks hot
you know i thought she was puerto rican
or caribbean dominican or some way she
was dancing
but she looked nice and you know i have
to keep my eyes on her whatever she
danced seemed like she danced forever
and i was trying to catch her attention
to go see if she wanted to dance so
you know she just disappeared on my side
all sudden she walks in front of me
and she steps on my toe with about it
seems like a six inch heel
whatever yeah crazy and i was like oh my
god you know
you know i was in pain so when i get up
like you know you know that like the
manly like
would you like to dance yeah yeah yeah
here we go
would you like to dance and that was the
beginning man
yeah we started dancing and dancing out
of the way and then one thing led to
another
and we started dating you know
we dated for about a year and a half she
was a mother of two divorced had been
recently moved to
houston from mexico city and uh you know
she told me her
story that she moved to the united
states for a better life for herself and
her two kids
uh she came from an abusive relationship
uh so she wanted a better life you know
so we dated for about a year and a half
after
after a year and a half we got married
uh the first three years of the marriage
was perfect you know she
treated me like a king uh manicure
pedicure massages was like oh
wow that's nuts well it was like the you
know the ultimate you know
yeah we you know she was at the
beginning she was okay with my kids
chris didn't live there yet he was out
here in l.a
but uh he was she treated my other mia
and my older son you know
she was i remember i remember the no i
was still
i didn't move to l.a until 2013. so like
i said we yeah yeah no
but she was okay with you know she was
kind of yeah yeah everything she was
always kind of playing the
the you know sweet sweet like you know
trying to be on the good side
you know what she wants us to to accept
her yeah
you know on her best behavior yeah yeah
yeah yeah she was just like you know
trying to be the the perfect
uh one she always had a little feeling
i was always kind of i was always kind
of just like she's too she's
kind of too too too nice yeah and you
know but uh
again you know from my point of view i
thought she was
the right person yeah so you know we
like i said mary for the first three
year was perfect you know
uh and the love is a little detail here
she was in houston
with the visitors visa from mexico city
okay so every six months she had to go
back to
to text me to mexico to review to renew
her visa
to stay in texas and uh and
so she didn't like that you know royal
she it was kind of tough on her
but right after we got married she
became she got a green card american you
know she became a resident of the united
states
and and things you know we're okay and
then we started having
little family issues well you know
especially with their older son you know
he was a teenager
but you know what it was you know just
like when you when when you have
uh kids from uh you know you try to
merge families sometimes
it's kind of it's kind of hard and the
young man knew he never really had a
father figure
and and i was you know a little tough on
him and not not physically i was just
being tough for him because i wanted to
be
grow up to be a man and be a responsible
man yeah and he wasn't responsible with
with education he wasn't responsible you
know with behavior
he just didn't give a damn you know and
then he wanted to be the man of the
house and i'm like oh hold up man
there's only one man in this house and
that's me yeah you know
i put a roof over your head closing your
back and
foot in your stomach you're gonna do
what i say it's my way of the highway
it doesn't work you know so it was tough
with them that's what
i think with the where the problem
started with is with with that the
little relationship with the you know
with that relationship with her son
she was a little she was also a little
she had a little jealousy too man cuz
like
you know my dad he praises you know his
three kids
like i mean he's still to this day like
i mean there's a facebook post every day
about
look at my three kids look look at my
first boy
there's always a post or something that
he's always putting up like that my baby
girl look what she's doing or this
and now that he has grandkids like my
sister has a son and my brother has a
son and um
you know uh he he always he's always
like that and so
i think that also that when you know you
look at her kids versus
us you know my dad was always just
talking about us and she's kind of just
like well you know what's up with ours
and my dad's like well
yeah what's up with yours cuz yeah your
kids look like
you know you know your boys acting like
a little [ __ ] when my kids are out
here
are the [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
like he's flunking around in school and
she's like that and it's like
i think that's another issue too that
she had she started getting a little
uh jealousy like like chris said with my
kids because she saw that my kids were
being so
successful graduated from school and
they were doing that thing going to
college mitchell and mitch with chris
started doing his thing and mia
my daughter was still in going to school
and you know doing well
and she was having a lot of issues for
their kids but one thing led to another
so it was you know we opened up a
business together you know uh
in the boxes because i was still
involved with boxing i already had a
non-profit
boxing gym and then uh we opened up a
big business the boxing gym woodlands
boxing the black
woodlands boxing and fitness and that
gym did very very well you know we're
very very successful
financially and you know we had a big
home you know nice toys motorcycles
you know living well and everything was
good you know
uh so one thing led to another and we
still were having ups and downs like in
every marriage you know
uh things didn't work out so in the year
2015 we decided you know just
just go our own way just get divorced
and
you know no divorce is easy you know
divorces are sometimes get a little
difficult but
in my situation we just went to the next
level um
because when she wanted to when she
asked for the divorce i said okay you
know whatever what
was her idea yeah it was her idea
because you know she in hindsight i'll
tell you later what i really what i
really thought that
it was all about but okay you know no
problem we just go through the divorce
you know i i was we could we're not
going to
live together and we can we can we can
get my first rodeo
listen i did it once before i'm used to
this [ __ ]
let's get it yeah i've done this before
yeah so anyway uh
but the thing was that she wanted to
make it difficult she wanted everything
you know like whoa
whoa i don't know how you guys do this
in mexico but in the united states you
know we we split everything in half
yeah you know she wanted the business
the house everything and she just wanted
you know just me to get you know go back
to
whatever i was doing no no no that's not
how i work exactly i work
way too hard for everything that we have
and i don't mind splitting it
in in whatever but you know it's crazy
that you're still like you're actually
okay with half
like you know because most people they
you know they talk about prenups and you
leave what i got and you leave what you
had and
stuff that you're like no no we'll just
do half and i'm good with that yeah like
[ __ ] you
just get having this sell this house
split it up do whatever yeah yeah so so
that's
what i wanted and but she didn't want it
you know but obviously because uh
uh now this is when it gets crazy uh
let me go back to the year 2000 you know
that's that's when i had a young man
coming to my gym
named mundo that's the real name but you
know that's that's that's the name
because he was a uh next gang member oh
[ __ ] yeah
so in the year 2000 a young man named
mundo walked into my gym
and overweight you know he didn't want
to become a boxer he just wanted to uh
learn how to box because when he was
young he didn't get the opportunity he
said he you know
he wanted to block but he couldn't for
whatever reason he couldn't do it and uh
so then he took the the right of
becoming a gang member
because he where he lived in the east
side of houston that's what's you know
what was happening and uh at the time he
came into my gym he had
just gotten out of prison he had been
locked up for a few years
he had been stabbed you know he's one he
had you know he was just
but he had changed his life around and
he wanted to go you know
join boxing to lose weight and you know
just because he loved boxing
uh so he became my my right hand man i
you know he loved being around my kids
he was a wonderful wreck to
you yeah no he's dope was i think it was
2010 but
no no no but he never talked about when
he first came into my gym over there you
know
in in texas yeah i went to the house it
was late it was in the years or whatever
it was a long time ago yeah and anyway
so
he wasn't he came into my life you know
he was a real close person in my life
so when i moved to the woodlands area
which is a suburb of houston where i had
my gym
he came back and found me where the gym
was at and we you know we just
after a few years of not being connected
he
became part of my life again and then i
told my ex-wife which was
you know lulu who's her nickname i told
him what he don't know his background
and we know how we have met and all that
stuff
she was okay with that you know she also
she wasn't really okay with him being a
gang member in his background and being
around the gym because he thought oh man
what everybody starts stealing from us
and all you know all the negative stuff
but uh he became a real close friend
yeah munoz real real close family friend
cool cat so he helped me around the gym
and you know he closed
the gym for me and clean and when
on saturdays when i couldn't make it he
would always be there and close it for
me
so uh one afternoon we were going this
is why we were still going through
my divorce one evening i wasn't at the
gym and mundo was there
with my ex-wife and her daughter and my
ex-daughter i mean my ex-wife and her
daughter
they're in my office in the gym office
having a conversation
and mundo just happened to walk into the
conversation
and my ex-wife lulu or know his her
daughter's is talking to her telling her
uh that there's there's a kid in the gym
that uh knows that has family in mexico
that kills people and chops people up
for money
and my ex-wives responds by oh we might
be able to use them
what the [ __ ] exactly and mundo just
happened to walk
by and he was like you know same thing
basically like what
yeah yeah so you know my cousin
so uh so he he tells he he's like whoa
whoa whoa you know
he kind of snapped his head because he
already knew that me and her were going
through a tougher
you know very tough divorce and he goes
whoa you need to you know
pay attention i mean be careful what you
say around people you know when you talk
like that because you never know who
might be walking up
yeah so that that situation happened
right so later on that evening
mundo just waited till everybody left
the gym and it was just her and
and and mundo and and her and my ex-wife
lulu
so he waited for her to be alone and he
walked up to her and said man
the little conversation you guys were
having in the office with with your
daughter
uh is this about is that about ramon and
she goes yeah man
she's totally she my ex-wife told him
like i wish he would just you know go
away you know we said
i wish they would just take him away i
can't stand them and you know because at
the time we were still living in the
same home
yeah and she was like i just can't i
just can't make it i just
i wish they would just take him away and
mundo
the decision that the young man took
right there on that spot is the reason
that i'm alive today
he told her you taking you talking about
take him away like this like
he made the pistol sign like you take
him away like this and she goes yeah
take him away
and he said you know what i got the
people that can do the job
oh slick smooth
right there on the spot i got the people
that can do the job and she was like she
was so desperate that she goes
oh really okay well let's let's talk
knowing that you know he's a gang so he
has a whole background
but he's really doing it like i'm about
to save my
he saw my dad as a father figure so he
was like hey cause you saved that
i'm about to save my pops real quick so
he's like i got the people that can
handle it
so that boy is slick yeah so he and even
though that she knew that he knew
that he's real close to me she was so
desperate like oh man you know he's yeah
he's he's getting ready you know we're
gonna do this to do this and he was also
giving her details of like
but this is what happened details is
like the next day
mundo i'm you know the next morning i'm
driving i remember i was driving and
mundo calls me
i was talking about like how he was more
convincing to her
saying like yo like yeah like you go out
you
you leave texas that way and i'll leave
texas this way like like he wanted a
piece of the pie too
oh yeah yeah he could like kind of like
kind of persuading her also making
he's good dude yeah yeah he's a perfect
man he's a professional yeah
that's what made it more convincing not
just like i'll get it done
yeah it was more of kind of an idea of
like all right bev we're going to do
this like
i need a little piece of the cut you
know to where she was like
all right you know yeah so she fell for
that all right so mundo calls me the
next morning while i'm driving
and he tells me hey pops you know uh
this lady she wants to kill you
and yeah i'm like at first i thought he
was joking because you know he went
who the [ __ ] is like yeah we're
splitting everything in half
he likes to joke around we're like we're
[ __ ] joking around man this is not
what are you talking about say yeah man
lulu she you know she wants to kill you
i say mundo quit [ __ ] quick what the
hell would you what are you talking
about he goes man
then he explained to me what had
happened that in the previous evening
when he walked into that conversation
man let me tell you david i pulled off
the road
to the and i was like what that closed
my eyes i was so
pissed i was yeah there's so many
emotions going through me i'm like what
the f
and then i had to go i was on my way
home and i had to see this lady
so i'm like thinking what the [ __ ] so me
and mundo he talked to me and said look
man
he said pop this is what we're gonna do
this is the the what i told her last
night see
we're supposed to meet and what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna uh
sit and you know i'm gonna take myself
my phone i'm gonna record all the
conversations
and see how far she's willing to go with
this i'm like [ __ ] all right man go
ahead let's do
do what you gotta do and then we'll see
what's gonna happen and i was like
and then i have to go home and see this
lady so i'm at home and even though
we're
going through a divorce we're still
living in the same house because i got i
have a two-story home she's living
upstairs
with her kids and her mother at the time
and i'm living downstairs
so we like living with this tension
already in my home and now on top of
this
i know and she doesn't know that i know
she's trying to kill me
holy [ __ ] so i'm sleeping one eye open
thinking like what the hell is going on
here
so i can't believe you went back to the
house
i would have built a
[Laughter]
but i was trying to keep it as cool as
possible to see you know if it was for
real
yeah so mundo kept having conversations
with her and sure enough you know after
mundo
would meet with her during the day or
whenever they would meet
he would record all the conversations
and then later on he would meet with me
in the evening
and we would i would listen to her
conversations
and i'm like i cannot believe what i was
saying the stuff she was saying
the things that she was saying that that
that she was tired of the you know how
the divorce was going
that he wasn't going her way that that
she felt like if
if that i was going to get more than she
was and she was just tired she was all
about money basically it was all yeah
money that was it you know i had at that
time i had
stopped going to the gym i said you know
because you feel like she can take care
of the gym so i left the gym
so the the membership started going way
way down because
i wasn't around yeah so the business was
crumbling slowly
so that was on you know her mind too
like you know i'm not getting the same
you know we're not getting money like
we're used to and i'm you know my bills
are all you know so everything's just
crumbling yeah so uh mundo tried to get
as much information as she could
and this is when it gets a little more
crazier so mundo uh one evening goes
hey man so i got an idea because he's
the street guy yeah i'm just i'm not a
street person i'm just a fighter that
happens to be you know so you guys this
is what the here's what the deal is
coach i mean so pops i'm gonna do uh
i'm gonna bring in i'm gonna tell her
that i got the two guys that are gonna
do
the job because she already believes
that i have the two guys
and he came up with two these two names
he goes i'm gonna call one john boy and
the other one paco
but here's the deal i want you to go get
a phone a tracfone
okay and i'm gonna text with her i'm
gonna be texting you
okay with in front of her and you're
going to play your own hit man
she's going to think i'm texting john
boy or paco but i'm really texting you
damn this boy good fam
this is a yeah i would never think of
this idea
yeah so he does that he goes and meets
with her
and then before that we practice
vehicles i'm not i don't know street
language i don't you know i don't i
didn't grow up like that yeah so he
tells me what to
what to text back and forth in the
language you know lingo say the n word
multiple times
[Laughter]
i never told you to say
but it was a crazy stuff because he told
me what to say and you know and you know
it was like spanglish basically it was
all it was spanglish street you know
street language but he's in spanglish
so here we go
that's that's basically what we did so
he gets in front you know they're
he's texting me like i'm paco and john
boy so
in front of her so he sends a comment i
mean a text me say
saying that hey uh you know are you
ready you know
you know how much you want for the
little toy and it that was
the toy was the key word for the gun and
i texted back look i got i got the toy i
need a minimum
i need at least 200 to get that for down
payment if not we know this is it
we need like we need at least 200 for
the toy
and she fell for it she gave him 200 on
the spot
holy [ __ ] to start the job just for the
gun for the dirty gun
and that's when we took all that
evidence me and mundo
well actually because mundo was you know
when i was when i talked about you know
saying
look we got enough evidence we have the
money we have her talking we have all
the video
i mean after all the audio let's just
i'm going to go to the police i thought
that you know
our own amateur investigation we thought
we had her
so we took it you know mundo goes up in
but you know what this is where it stops
for me man i don't go to the police i
don't talk to police it's your job now
yeah
i'm like oh [ __ ] so i went to the police
and first of all where i lived it was a
very middle class
upper middle class suburb they were like
oh [ __ ] we never had anything like this
yeah especially in our suburb yeah
they're like what in the hell exactly
you know how to be hispanics
jesus christ trying to get them out of
here yeah i know
exactly so anyway so they you know they
took my information but they said look
man we
you know you see what's going on and but
we need mundo
winning his side yeah because we need
both you guys
story and then we see you know what
we're going to do so i had a big moon
though and and
finally he said okay man i just go ahead
and do it for you so they recorded you
know we went and did and they
didn't tell them our stories and they
had to make sure
he talked to himself and not talking
about himself and they match
whatever so everything matched so it's
like oh [ __ ] this is for real
because the thing was that my divorce
was coming up in about a month
to be to be you know ended and
in one of the recordings lulu goes it
tells mundo look
he needs to die before this date because
if he dies
before our divorce is over because if he
dies after that
his kids you know before if he doesn't
die for you know
you know everything was like my kids
were going to get everything
but if he dies before you know that the
divorce goes through then
yeah they're still technically married
so she'll get everything yeah
so that was the thing she was in a hurry
so the the police had to act quick so
they brought in the texas rangers the
troopers
fbi they brought a whole group of people
and then they said okay we're going to
come in and you know since she already
knows one of the one of the uh
hitmen says john boy we're going to
bring our own undercover cop to talk to
her
so they brought in another cop on an
undercover cop
to talk to her live now this is
i'm no longer drunk with he's like on
the phone no no no live
oh yeah yeah real quick yeah
in person yeah yeah the n word in the
beginning
that's the only way i'll believe you and
i was like yeah man they they had
because he played john boy
yeah and so so mundo was still mundo and
then the paco was just like through text
whatever but then they were like okay
you're gonna meet john boy in a car
and the car cop yeah the car was hot
wired the car had
all these cameras all different angles
she had no idea she had no idea it was
in the middle of a parking lot
outside of a uh academy and uh
and that's when they when she's telling
when he said hey look you know this is
about to happen
so but we need you know because they the
the hit was supposed to be for fourteen
thousand dollars
jesus and then uh she said well i don't
have the money right now
but i can give you jewelry and i can
give you
are they financing um everybody's chance
oh my god that was basically what you
know she's not giving my son he's a
loser
but he's strong he can work the fields
so she said no
no she said okay i don't have that money
i can give you two thousand dollars in
cash
i'll give you some jewelry and he and
the vehicle that he drives you know when
when i get him you know even the watch
is nice because i haven't done a nice
watch
yeah you know get up get all that you
know and then but the thing is when he
dies i will have all the money because i
will have all the pension all the all
the insurance money she's gonna pay you
the rest of the money
but guess whose jewelry she gave them
who's my jewelry
my watches my rings my wedding bands
all that was part of the down payment
plus from money from my bank account
she's sending pictures to the the trap
phone the john boy phone
she's sending pictures of my dad's truck
my dad's drew and all these things and
my dad's looking at the pictures coming
in
he's like [ __ ] she's
audacity she's sending me pictures like
oh what do you think about this is this
you know i was like yeah yeah she had no
idea the whole time there were those
pictures
like none of her own [ __ ] yeah yeah bro
your boxers like these boxers are real
nice
it's a thousand thread count it feels
good but yeah that's that's basically
what that you know and then
this is what you know after they had
gathered enough information they had the
video they had the audio they had the
money
and i thought that was it i said oh no
they got her now she's done
they bring me in to the police
department one night and said
and i don't know why it had to be in the
evening because i was like it's kind of
it was kind of creepy
yeah that they brought me through the
back and they and they brought me to
this office
and they had the d.a was there the fbi
they had a whole group of people on this
table
and the d.a tells me uh ramon uh we just
want to talk to you about
the situation i think we have enough
evidence uh
to know that this [ __ ] is crazy yeah
what else do you need
god damn yeah but uh uh you know we just
want this case to be a slam dunk case
she's a beautiful lady
she has two kids she's never been in
trouble she's known about around the
community you guys have a business here
a lot of people guys
a lot of people know you guys i mean
y'all here so we just need to be
this to be a slam duct case we don't
want to go to a jury trial and have a
drawer
feel sorry for her and then you know
that's it
so uh they said what we're gonna do
we're gonna take a picture
you dead and show it to her
oh so i had to fake my own death
yeah so yeah yeah
they uh they show them chris they they
is it on you guys you got it on your
phone i know it's all your favorites
dude
you'll see the pictures so anyway but
he's already before you show them links
so this is what happened they
the d.a pulls up a bunch of pictures of
actual dead people
i mean people that have been shot to the
head
bullet went to the head and and they
were all like okay
well they had to pick one to to so they
can rip replicate it on me
holy [ __ ] some kind of you know
hollywood story
yeah yeah yeah you know and so they said
i don't even know they could do stuff
like that that's
crazy you think it's crazy not gonna
even be more crazier
because they said okay we're gonna just
uh uh
take the picture what
yeah yeah that's crazy right that's
nuts but listen to me dave this is what
this is what you know believe this
so in the picture in the picture it's uh
for those who are listening
uh it's it's my dad inside of a uh
inside of a hole they they dug up a hole
in
a room
well the the d.a goes okay this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna disappear you
for three days
you cannot nobody can hear you cannot
call anybody that
no nobody because we're going we want
her to believe that you're dead
you're going to bring you want to go
home get you a change of clothes
don't tell anybody where you're at so
not even mundo needs to know where
you're at
so and then you're going to bring you in
we're going to put the makeup on you
and we're going to take it to a shallow
grave that we already have and we'll
take pictures of you
and then show her the pictures of you
being dead
so when they brought me in then i went
home and i was like
and at this time i was right out of the
house and when they got me a
change of clothes i came back for three
days you know for three days whatever
and then they put me in this room and
then these two officers come in with
this little kit
and i'm thinking these guys are
professional you know makeup artists and
stuff yeah
these dudes that had just watched that
[ __ ] two days prior
the night before on youtube that's
hilarious
they had just seen that but you know how
to fake a murderer how to fake uh you
know bullet wounds from this little
video from you know make from halloween
basically
i'm like oh you have to be kidding me
man so what
the [ __ ] exactly i'm thinking and then i
know her she's real good
with with porter shopping all that stuff
and i'm thinking man she's not gonna
fall for this she's gonna see this be
like
yeah she's not gonna fall for this man
yeah but anyway they put on the makeup
and everything they took me out they had
a a
a little uh you know the van you know
the way they put me in
all blacked out suv they had some cops
you know everybody was following
us they took me to this area
he was in the middle of the woods i'm
like what the hell
i mean that was my thought when i was
driving what am i going what the hell am
i doing
yeah and so they said okay we're gonna
get you get naked down to your underwear
we'll get down to your underwears
and put getting that and lay down they
told me how to lay down put my head back
and everything
i had my eyes closed and all i hear is
the clicking of that 35 millimeter
non-stop taking pictures walking around
me taking pictures
and i was just the the thing that i was
thinking what i was thinking the most
was about my kids i was like what are my
kids gonna think when they see this
yeah my family my mother my my family
when they see this
and i'm like this well i wasn't is right
at the moment but i'll say it like now
like looking at him like gosh you
believe that [ __ ]
yeah so they took me crazy they took me
away to a hotel
outside outside of town for three days
they took my phone away they took the
phone away from the hotel room
i was like practically yeah off the grid
and
locked in yeah for the next three days
so
and then they had a uh security there
watching me the whole time
the hotel anyway the next day
they went to my business and did a
missing person report on her with a real
cop
and this you know and then they asked
hey you know this is uh such and such
i'm
here for missing personal report from
ramon so so we haven't been seen
whatever for the next
well she started you showed they showed
her the picture though no no before that
i was before i'm sorry the night the
night before the night before that they
they met with her the undercover cop met
with her in
mundo in the back seat and to let her
know they said look man we got we got we
got the job done
so they wanted to meet with her to prove
that look you know we got a picture to
show you that he's dead
so she walks he gets in the car and
everything like no big deal
and they showed her the picture and said
look man he's done and these videos are
online too like
yeah they can youtube it and see the
video of her
going to the car and the reaction of her
seeing the people when they show the
picture
her first reaction she starts laughing
like she thought it was funny she go oh
and the first thing when she was in
spanish said well he's not getting up
right
he goes no he's done he's dead he said
he fought you know he fought a hell of a
fight
he fought one of the other guys he beat
up my other friend but now we got him i
like how they gave
my dad a little time
right yeah i died with dignity i beat
the [ __ ] out of the other one but we
still
put it to the head yeah so they got me
right so she was like oh wait she
started racing her hands like she like
she
hit the lotto get
my grandma bro she was just saying like
oh man i'm just i'm done
good like like it's done cool yeah like
shook his hand
gave him money all that yeah so
so the next day they did a missing
person report
you know they went to my gym and that
happened when she had no idea
the undercover cops had my gym
surrounded
watching her the whole day my whole my
gym this woman is insane
so they have been watching her so they
you know then this
this actual officer two of them show up
to my gym
and they do a missing person report on
me you know went to the office and she
was there
in the office in front of her mother and
daughter and asked her about me and they
you know remember the night before she
was all happy and
like she hit the ladder and everything
no she was worried she's also on youtube
as well
the body cam video of the cop coming up
to her that's also on youtube
she's she's actually like she's acting
like she's worried now like oh no i
don't know i
i try to call him sister i try to call
his friend and yeah i don't know where
he's at i don't know what's going on
and man she's really excited and even
that she played a good day she even
asked
her her mother like mom when was the
last time you say oh i don't know i
thought it was wednesday or something
when we saw
and the obviously okay lulu maria you're
on an arrest for solicitation and
capital murder
and they took her out and her mom and
her daughter
handcuffed cuffed gone and everybody's
like what's going on and mom like what's
going on well the daughter shouldn't
know cause you talking to the doctor but
she knows she had they all acted like
they went
whatever they didn't know but they're
arrested right there on the spot
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] got her
that girl is nuts yeah she started
celebrating when she saw your picture
yeah
that's crazy laughing and celebrating
like yeah bro put her hands up
that was the [ __ ] that that really like
i was like what the [ __ ] that's like
when she's done
it's like fam nobody's just looking at
the picture of my
my dad dead bro like laughs with a
bullet in his head and she's just like
he's you sure you ain't gonna get up
really like i had no idea she could do
windmills like she started doing windows
on the floor [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] what'd you learn how
to you're a b-boy now
[ __ ] yeah so it's so much
and then and then when i do i found out
was like when when they arrested her
the officers they called me for they
didn't call me they went into the room
and and knocked in the door and said i
mean we got her they explained to me
and that's when it really hit me like
damn man you know i sat on the edge of
my bed
put my head down and i kept thinking
about everything like wow
what it came down to you know i mean you
could have yeah
because i didn't know i didn't i didn't
know you know she had a plan b or c
and say oh i don't know what's going on
yeah so she actually like contacted
anybody in mexico and stuff like that
so you know i get in my car and i'm
rushing again you know i've got my phone
trying to call my parents
i turn on my car headline news in
houston
women gets arrested for solicitation of
capital murder
uh we will have a uh news conference and
justin such time
it made hitler you know it was all over
the news holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and this is
what's so crazy another thing that
happened is like i try to call my
parents you know because i know
by this time they already know and sure
enough you know when i called my
my mom my father answered the phone
and they just happened to be my mom my
sis my mom they were housing in my
sister's home because my sister was out
of the country
and i hear my mom you know those kind of
cries you hear at a funeral
yeah where it's like you know it's
different you know the funeral cries
differently
of course and then she's just oh my god
wailing and my father's first thing is
like what's going on in spanish also you
know the
monkeys yeah and i think the way that
was explained by my father was like
she had walked in the in the house to
get some water from my dad that was
outside you know working on the
yard and then when she walked by my
sister's
you know tv the big screen she just saw
the news
that they had arrested my ex-wife and
she understood that i was
dead oh my god
and then when you called her she was
like a ghost
so that's what she understood that i was
dead she didn't know there was a murder
for her oh my god
yeah so it was it was crazy man and then
after that was
but she had one last black card to play
my ex-wife
one last one because when she got she
got arrested
and she was uh after about a month
after being locked up i was hurt back in
my house
i get a knocked on the door from an uh
detective or lady detective and she
serves me with papers
and she goes ramon sauce and said yes i
said uh she says you've been served by
maria
sosa my ex-wife she's filing rape
charges on you
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] not she is out of
her
[ __ ] mind what is wrong with her that
was the last card to play
she's have been locked yeah i've been
locked up for for a month or month a
little bit over a month
and she follows a rape charge on me
saying that i had raped her
when i was we were together and i was
like
and i told her do you know you just go
oh yeah trust me i know everything
that's happening
i know your case i know exactly what's
going on but we still have you know
because she filed charges on you of rape
charges
i just have to start the papers yeah
yeah we still have to go and do an
investigation
i said you know what let's go do the
polygraph right now i'll take the test i
do it whatever it takes
this you know i told i was pissed yeah
and she goes i understand sir
just calm down talk to your attorney and
and and then we'll come back to you
and sure enough my attorney you know
he's the dumbest thing yeah
yeah he was like don't worry about it i
know what's going on she's just trying
anything she can to get out of this so
we'll take care of it i didn't take my
polygraph you know and of course
he's not admitted in court but they they
they
you know it didn't go anywhere you know
she was just trying anything
and that's [ __ ] crazy and she just
wanted to hurt you
yeah and after about 15 months in prison
she
pleaded down she pleaded guilty
basically
to solicitation to capital murder second
degree and she got 20 years
damn she's doing 20 years right now the
texas women penitentiary
what in the holy [ __ ] no
how lucky are you yeah yeah yeah
and damn that was but hey let me tell
you i got a book
i got a book called i walked on my own
grave
a true crime story you have a book yeah
yeah i need to read that [ __ ] on amazon
that [ __ ] is nuts yeah and that's where
that goes into all the details
and you're going to be like i don't have
time to explain everything because
there's a lot yeah of course but it is
jaw-dropping everything that happened
and you're like it gets a little too
detailed i was like i ain't have to know
about all that
i don't even know why my dad put that in
the book i'm like dad i know we get down
but damn
the day i had sex it's like okay let's
cut that [ __ ] out real quick
man he put some stuff in there i'm like
this is part of the story
because you know she was she was a good
manipulator
and she knew how to use her beauty her
charm that was her mouth obviously
evidently oh god yeah
you read the book you started screaming
at night oh my god i was like
all right i was there and i had to like
close it like all right
okay it was it was but you know it was
raw but it is is to the point where
you understand like everything
so it was i mean so for her like in your
case
she was a con artist she was the perfect
psychopath yeah she was the she played
her part so well she was like i'm going
to be
the quote unquote best woman you know
textbook woman
massages whatever like stuff that goes
above and beyond what you know any woman
would normally do for anybody
right and then she kind of like got you
in this fantasy world
yeah that's nuts and what's so crazy is
is that i would bring it you know
it got to the point where i was so
pissed that i would bring it up to her
like did you just get married to me if
you know to become an american citizen
and now that you have a
you know you have money you know you
have a good home you have everything
so everything was all about money and
and you know but what happened then she
goes look and this is what she turned
everything around look
look at me look at my body look at me i
can get any man
i can get any man i want i met a lot of
men before you
a lot of men before you that had a lot a
lot more money than you
i only won them i wanted you i fell in
love with you
then she'd take it to the bed holy [ __ ]
yeah it's so crazy
that is scary as [ __ ] did you get
remarried after that no
see that's right good move i
would be so traumatized my palms are
sweating right now just thinking about
that
the fact that somebody would go that far
to kill you
like i'm gonna give you a little another
little hint that happened this is all in
the book but this is you know kind of
i uh two years prior like in the year
2013
we had gone to mexico on vacation
because you know and the thing was so
funny that she had details she was very
good at detailing
every little place that we were going to
be at how long we're going to be there
and we're you know of course i don't
know nothing about mexico cities i've
never been there so she named all these
different places where we're supposed to
be at in a time
a certain time and how much time we will
be there yeah so
after vacation we come back whatever we
are seeing and you know whatever we'll
come back
and and one of the conversation this is
after of course
2015 one of the conversations that she
had with mundo
undercover she tells mundo that
she wanted to kill me two years prior in
2013 when we're in mexico city
and mumbai goes
yeah i had it all planned with my sister
and what the
[ __ ] and her sister had been to my house
this lady i had you know we were like
cool her sister i've been to my house he
lived with me for a little while
live with us you know very you know
whatever
she was like i was like the nicest
person to to her family to her
and her sister so the plan was and when
they go so what what
what was that what were you planning on
doing and she goes well the plan was
that
we i talked to my sister and the plan
was that we were going to have
us both me and me and me and ramon have
us uh
uh held for ransom you know because in
mexico that's big over there to say that
they were gonna held
us for ransom that's like a normal job
yeah that's not bad
but it happens to a lot of people yeah
you know i always said because like i
know of i mean we're just gonna
sidetrack for a second but there was a
there was a kid
i'm not saying it happens a lot but it's
pretty crazy out there just because i
used to do mexican
mission trips when i was a uh my
father's a pastor so we used to do a lot
of mission trips in mexico but
one of the things that a lot of locals
would warn us was of cartel stuff yeah
so that shit's like real yeah
there was a there's a story that you
guys would probably look up online but
there was a kid
who was uh taken for ransom by cartel by
uh this mission trip it wasn't my church
but it was my friend's church
and this girl went missing right uh long
story short with that
i mean look it up online you guys
probably find this story but
they took her and they asked money to
get her back
and her parents were like okay well we
don't have this money so they just
started gathering money through like the
church or whatever something like that
it's a story that i heard
uh sent them half the money they're like
cool you get your daughter back they
sent half the kid back
wow yeah yeah [ __ ] nuts dude
but you know what i'm saying is that it
but it's it's you know those type of
[ __ ] yeah those type of especially when
when they know that you have a little
bit of money
and that's how they that's how they get
you know when you say for ransom
and that's what the plan was they were
going to hold us both
for ransom in one of those little
locations that she already had marked on
her
itinerary yeah she has a vacation
itinerary is that what it was
tortillas go to the beach
and then hold ramon for ransom
and then dance and go dancing
but david you were so crazy the little
town the little place that she says that
uh that supposedly was
the ransom place where they were going
to hold us up is in a
a place called tepito and debito
come to find out is is like the slums
you know like those the places you know
over there you know
like tijuana and stuff like that yeah
it's a slum area where you can find
anything and she and i said i said what
do we want to go there i mean i want to
go see no slum
yeah he's oh no no it's a place that you
see you find anything you want
it's just a place you're going it's very
interesting he said hey yeah i have
everything i said what the hell do i
want to go see this
yeah sounds great yeah it sounds great
what the [ __ ] exactly we have a walmart
back at home we're good
we have everything so she went but i
you know i just said i don't want to go
there when we were there i said i want
to go see that crap you know yeah so we
never went
and lo and behold that's why you're
alive so the thing was that you know
that was a challenge she wasn't
persuasive but she's like you sure
you want to go no i'm good but aren't
you sir
yeah no i'm good but that was that was
the plan she
the sister said that that that that was
when they were gonna let
her go the the people that were held for
ransom they were gonna let her go and
then they want to keep me and kill me
yeah and her sister said you know that
she said well you know bring him over
here don't worry about it you know
people disappear mexico all the time
they'll never find them
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that bro
that's how crazy it was and mundo asked
her how come you didn't do it
and he goes she goes well i didn't have
the heart to do it then but now i do
the heartbeat you were thinking about
i've never what listen let me tell you
something
my fiancee has pissed me off many times
i've never thought about killing her
so when did you start seeing signs like
things were going bad was it right when
you guys got married oh
let me tell you something right in a
little red flag
that i should have been like oh [ __ ]
that no wonder
we got married at a uh it was a like
small celebration
at a courthouse but it was all you know
dresses and everything she had a little
she's genuine yeah everything
so after a little wedding her mother
walks up to me she was at the winter who
was genuine
you know she was glad she was so no you
know how she was she was detailed with
everything genuine
genuine you know what i'm talking about
whatever genuine is is
in them genes
sorry that's how the og saying all right
i was like wait a minute my bad boss i
just had
[Laughter]
her mother walks up to me right after we
got i mean right after we took her
taking our vows
she comes up to me goes and
congratulates congratulates me
and just whispers in my ear now she's
your trouble
and walks away
she's like trying to kill her mom and
[ __ ] too her mom's like always holding
the top of her drink like this
she's like
because i know because i know that's
your problem
yeah man that was that was that was
right off the bat
i never forget it when mom told me just
whisper in my ear
no she's your trouble that's crazy
that's so frightening to me yeah well i
gotta have a talk with my fiance now
it's like what are you up to real quick
yeah yeah yeah changing my [ __ ] cup
like this all the time
yeah that's nice and sleeping i mean
sleeping in the
same bed knowing that you're you know at
the time she was we were still married
like
i don't know if this [ __ ] has a plan b
or c
yeah because who knows right yeah i mean
mundo didn't work okay
let me call paco yeah yeah i got a job
for you
wow so mundo's still a part of your life
then right yeah yeah you know we're not
as close
as uh you know like we were before
because after everything that had that
doesn't happen you know what happened to
me
i just been more closer to my family
there was a few years there where i lost
because of her she put a wedge between
my kids and me
especially my youngest daughter yeah and
i lost that and and you know so i've
just gotten a lot more closer to my
family
and mundo although he's part of my
family i would always
love you know he'll be the reason that
i'm alive today
uh i just don't want him to god forbid
everything that happens i don't want to
be part that
it was because of me yeah there's a lot
of friends that i have taken you know
kind of pardon you know kind of being in
just just getting my distance i just you
know spend a lot of time out with my
kids my grandkids my parents
uh so it's it's so what's bundle doing
now because he was he was at the gym
before yeah you know he's he's he's
still ladies and gentlemen he got a book
he put came out with he's got his own
book called
my son mundo okay yeah there there was a
i think there was a time like when all
this stuff was really i'm
talking about like all over bro you
couldn't go online without seeing it
um there were there was just uh there
was just a time where it was just kind
of it was just a little weird like
because mundo was he didn't want to be a
part of it
and then he did want to be a part of it
but then he wanted to be blurred out
want to change his voice because he
didn't want to like
yeah yeah so so he kind of just was like
and my dad you know
my dad's cool with it like my dad you
know he'll he i mean he's been on
podcast now for like the past
two years now like being on interviews
and and these shows and all these things
and mundo was just staying low and um
yeah so we it just kind of just
you know just yeah he kind of kept the
little pro and yeah
you know he came out on one show and uh
one of those
crime shows and they promised him that
they were not going to show his face and
they did
and what the [ __ ] what's wrong with them
yeah that was a big issue too and so
he's kind of
he's always kept a low profile every
time we do interviews it's a good guy
though man
yeah yeah that was the first person i
talked to after my dad called me because
you know normally like i hear from my
dad
uh i'm back in la during this time like
you know i've been in la this was this
was like 2015.
and so you know i've been in l.a for two
three years now
and um now like you know i hear from my
dad every day but this time like i
haven't heard from in a week
this whole thing was happening and i
didn't i didn't also didn't really
like maybe i thought about it like i'd
really heard from my past but i
also didn't think about calling them
either i was just kind of like all right
well he'll hit me
whatever i'm doing my own thing so yeah
well you're not thinking this is
happening yeah
yeah everything that's like right i mean
they knew that i was going through a
divorce but not like you know
no crazy stuff yeah i had to keep it
that was one of the things that the
the the officers you know the undercover
had to be
the only people that knew was mundo and
me yeah nobody
yeah and i had to live with that stress
every single day going to the gym
i mean and it was crazy
she was over here she ruined my
non-profit uh she wrote a letter to my
biggest sponsor it was which it was a
big oil company
in the woodlands in uh texas i bet you
they feel bad now
yeah but if thing was the thing was you
know once they found out what really
happened
i wrote them you know they still didn't
want to help because they didn't want
their name attached
to my situation it actually would have
helped them out actually you know
yeah yeah it's not very smart of them
yeah man my dad called me and the way he
the way he broke it down i'm thinking
you know because my dad was just like yo
were you at us i'm
i'm at the house he was like so you got
to you have to sit down for this one i'm
like
i'm thinking somebody died bro like my
grandma or something like i'm like oh
god sit down thinking
you know who died not knowing that it
was my dad who died yeah you know me and
like hypothetically but you know they he
had faked it but
you know he broke it down to me and i
was just like wait what
yeah he said he broke this yeah he was
just like yeah like lulu tried to kill
me and
he gave me everything and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
and and then you know like i was like
all right wars mundo he's like you know
he's
you know he he just let me know like you
know you can call him just call him up
it's not
called mundo man i was just like bro
thank you bro like thank you so much man
you saved my dad's life man like i was
just like
and then mundo was just like hey man
like i see y'all as my fam you know what
i mean like
that's like a dad to me and y'all like
my bros and i just you know wanted to
look out you know
like i i was he was like his biggest
thing he
he said um i was thinking about uh your
dad's dad
like but i'm a senior you know he was
like i was thinking about him man and i
was just like man
like you know i can't i can't you know i
know how much because my my grandpa
he always just pops up at the gym you
know sometimes he'll come up every day
sometimes he'll just
randomly push up but my my grandpa loves
to
like be around himself he's a
professional wrestler so like he's been
around the ring all
you know up for that professionally he
was on tv and then there's the whole
thing so like oh wow
even when i was training like when i was
a kid and fighting my grandpa was always
there so like
he's always been in the picture so you
know he was just thinking about that
like man like imagine that you know what
i mean like you know he finds out his
son
you know it's gone you know so he was
just like man i was just like i was
thinking about you guys but then i was
thinking about his pops man i was
thinking about it
he thinks so fast on his feet that was
so quick for him to be like
it also makes me wonder what the [ __ ]
was mundo doing before all this like
he knew what's up oh yeah yeah yeah
right and what's ironic is
that you know you think about it ten
years prior that you know when
when i first met him i kind of helped
him you know turn his life around
yeah and save them from the streets and
all that you know mentoring them
yeah and he here comes back and saves my
life 15 years later
nuts and he had he had to tap into that
street life
that's helpful he had to go back to
being a you know basically so imagine
bro like all that [ __ ] he's gone through
all that [ __ ] he knew all that street
everything it came in handy like like
yeah but it's like for a reason
yeah i mean like for like good reason
for good for a good reason to save
somebody
rather than killing somebody so we don't
set this up with the fake person
you know another thing that he said was
that you know you know once you're in a
gang
you don't you don't you don't rat on
anybody i don't care if good or bad
you know so he was basically being a rat
yeah but he didn't say no i don't do
that
a little bit you know what he said but
you're different yeah you're different
you know i don't want you know he said
yeah i don't want you to die
he said i don't know if she had somebody
else to do the job
but he said we don't do this in gangs we
don't talk we don't we don't do this
yeah man that's crazy because i'm a big
ass snitch
i snitch on the [ __ ] super fast
dude what the [ __ ]
are you crazy i've been on this podcast
multiple times you better not [ __ ] up
around me i'm snitching you out dude
i'm trying to protect my life you
would've heard they're like oh [ __ ]
let me tell you what lulu just said let
me tell you if i meet lulu she's like
what do you say let me tell you what
[ __ ] remote said about [ __ ]
just in case she's over here with the
[ __ ] machete
get my ass i'm like oh [ __ ] hell yeah
bro
wow that's such a life-changing thing
you know because he kind of glanced
about like
like something crazy happened to you but
i didn't know it was like this yeah you
know what i mean
so i've been fortunate enough that i can
you know i talk a lot about my story
because there's so much more than i talk
about domestic abuse
against men because it happened in my
life
when it comes when it's yeah and would
she be was she somebody who was very
like verbally abusive
verbally physically oh she would hit you
and you know there were times when we
had you know saying but
but the reason she was doing it now i
know it was because she was she wanted
me to retaliate
and she's oh so she could do something
about it yeah he talked about that in
the book
man i read that i remember seeing that
in the book i'm not gonna give him
everything there cuz i know
no i don't know something they got to
read it for sure no but i saw that man
yeah and she hit him with a little sauce
and my dad my dad had to be like well
hello hello
hold on now like you know you know
you know yeah i have that i have a
fighter's instinct yeah that's right
that's what she was looking for for me
to retaliate yeah but she was just
wanting to use that against me
to basically you know put me in prison
the her thing was like
finding a way to either get me out of
the house locked me up she had her son
lie about me that are punching us he was
just had a whole
home telling you there was a uh
the episode on the uh on 48 on 48 hours
when they did my dad like uh
the episode about my dad now i've i've
heard this story all the time like i you
know and
i watch the interviews that has that
he's done on dateline all these things
and other podcasts and stuff but
on the 48 hours they showed a clip that
i've never seen
and it was a clip of of her son
antagonizing my dad basically following
my dad
outside of the house he's walking
towards his truck like
and he's in his his like fedex uniform
you know he's getting ready to go to
work
and he's following him and he's like
antagonizing like like
you know like uh he was just talking
[ __ ] right like what was he saying like
no he was
it it's a little longer straighter than
that the thing was that this
crazy nut i have a truck right yeah and
when i bought it when
you know buy we would pay i pay for a
cash whatever
and i told her to go get the title of
the truck you know that's when i thought
with things where things were still good
you know living you know the right
things were we're okay
so she never went and got the title
changed that's what i
think that went ahead and eventually so
one morning i'm going to
work whatever and i get pulled over
because i ran a red light it was my
fault you know i was kind of hurt when
the very light
so when i get to the officers come up to
me
you know they take their time in the
back i'm like what the hell is going on
so when they come up he goes um i see
the driver's license registry a regular
thing
he goes uh does this vehicle belong to
you sir
and i said yeah who is it register
to and i said what do you mean is mine
is me or is either me or my wife when we
ask oh no
i said what's going on i said well it
says here's registered to lewis paz i
said what
this [ __ ] had registered the name into
her son
his name wow and never told me anything
and that's how i found out
wow when i got pulled over but whatever
the thing was that the kid when that
happened was that he was trying to tell
me that that was his truck and he wanted
me out of the truck
and he was gonna call the police because
that's his vehicle
wow so he comes
so i'm just i'm watching because it's
from his phone so they have that
that that that footage so i'm watching
from his uh pov or whatever
and bro i'm just seeing my dad bro like
he's he's on the front seat
door open and he's just still like not
letting him close the door
and my dad's like trying to close it
he's not letting him close he's like get
out of my car that's my car
and my dad's like sitting there like he
kind of just looked like
really but like like like you know like
but they were all recording me
her mom his mom and his daughter was so
hard they were all in it together
did they not did they not go to jail
either no but this is what happened
i pulled the phone off his you know him
because i'm the one that pays all the
bills
yeah on the phone so that's my phone
technically i pulled the phone
so right there on the spot they call
9-1-1 i'm an abusive i'm enraged
you know whatever like i live in a cold
set
do like five cops pull up they pull me
to the side they put them over there
they listen to their side of the story
and then you have the video
listen no i don't have a video because
then i don't i don't have the code yeah
they had they they took the phone the
lady to the cops took the phone cause
they said you know whatever
they i tell my story and when they come
back
they come back and listen to me again
and say well sir uh he's saying that you
punched him
what the [ __ ] i said punched him and she
goes yeah he said i don't
i said where's the bruce and she goes i
know i don't see a bruise but
according to the mother and the daughter
they're saying that you punched them and
uh we need to
give you a citation for uh wow
so i got a ticket for the punch that i
never threw
so i wish i would have stocked and then
[ __ ] you know what i told you look look
let me tell you
i told him look i'm an ex-professional
boxer i have
coach i have a business that's in boxing
if i would have hit that kid
he would not be standing up right now
yeah he would not be standing up right
now
yeah you know what this little fool did
the next day he went to the gym at night
with his little friends that got drunk
and everything and they got in the ring
and he let one of his friends punch him
and he took a picture of it
and he gave it to the police saying that
was that it did that to him
wow wait what did the cops say after
that i mean no no they knew it was
fake and then they tried to take it to
the to the you know the
yeah she had her attorney their
attorneys were saying that all that
you know what they did he said that when
i took the phone away that's when they
stopped the video
and he said that's when i punched him
oh my god yeah bro but it was but you
know the thing was it was
when i when when my attorney uh you know
took him to court
for that case they never showed up wow
so he knew was fake so they didn't want
to take any chance so they didn't show
up
yeah that's [ __ ] nuts i can't believe
she divorced you
that's the crazy you are a man of
patience god has blessed you with
patience there's nobody that i know in
my circle
that would have taken that much abuse
but
like i said it was manipulation of the
mind
that and that's what i talk about when i
do a lot of the speeches you know for
domestic abuse
that man stands and sometimes men with a
lot of men that that are that are
that are that are uh uh you know in
abusive relationships
when there are the you know the victim
they're victim
they stand in the same way you know for
the same reasons that women stay either
it can be financial it could be either
love it could be kids [ __ ] [ __ ]
all those same reasons men stay and it
happens to a lot of men just that man
don't talk about it
and that could be a whole new podcast
you have how men stay in relationships
sometimes
because not because they're [ __ ] or
because they're less of a man like i
tell them you're not a [ __ ] you're not
less of a man
usually because you know you want your
relationship to work see i don't that's
not interesting because like i've never
thought about
like domestic violence the other way
right yeah nobody does a lot of people
don't and it happens more than people
most people think
because we only think about it in the
way of like the male
is physically stronger exactly right but
there's other stuff like
like mental abuse and like manipulation
exactly
you know threats you know i'll take my
kids and you'll never see your kids
again
financially you just say rape and it's
done yeah it's a wrap yeah you know what
i mean
i mean i tell you guys i'll give them a
little short you know story like look
if your wife hits you and you're
retaliated you hit her
and the cops come who are they going to
believe her
believe her most of the time nice out of
10 they're going to believe with her
story yeah but they're not going to
believe that she did
she put their hands on you first i'm
saying you know if a man commits
a crime against a sexual i mean abusive
against the lady
and and he's found guilty i you know
throw the you know the books at him
but when it happens to a lady you know
what they get most of them slap in the
hand yeah
you know there's men that are imprisoned
right now right now there's a lot of men
in prison
that are being that have been charged
for domestic abuse not all of them but
i'm sure there's a there's a lot of men
that have been charged with domestic
abuse falsely and then
you know they can't know about it i told
the story on this podcast
before but uh when i uh was younger
there was a dude um not my friend
all right i just knew of him but
there was a girl that was in a very um
interesting relationship right so she
was somebody who was very manipulative
right and
we brought this up during a time where
um people were saying like oh
all the time it's like guy's fault you
know when it comes to like these type of
situations but i was like i have a
couple of stories where it wasn't
i have one story which i'm not going to
go over but long story short this girl
basically
threatened her boyfriend saying that she
was going to go to the cops and tell him
that
they she he raped her if you broke up
with her yeah and it happens
right and i we were like yo this [ __ ]
girl is nuts
right and so she was threatening him
with all this other stuff that all got
figured out right we'll talk about that
story another time but
there's this other story where there was
a girl
who um basically convinced her current
boyfriend
that her ex-boyfriend raped her yeah
right and this guy that was her current
boyfriend is a
highly affiliated gang member they
executioner style killed this dude in
his driveway
like with a bunch of friends and they
shot him right in there
and then she was like shocked that he
actually [ __ ] did it
and but she's like in jail for life now
yeah right the guy actually has a lesser
sense of her because she was the
ringleader that kind of caused it all up
over her manipulating this guy you know
i mean this dude
who she broke up with too was the
opposite of what she normally dates like
he's like a really nice guy
and he wanted to be with somebody a
little different lo and behold he
decided to date a [ __ ] hood rat
like she's a hood rat to the max and he
broke up with her because he couldn't
handle it and in her mind
from what i believe from my point of
view was that she thought she grabbed
somebody finally great
right but she didn't change who she was
she was not a good person and what he
realized was
this i can't handle this girl broke up
with her and
she told her new boyfriend that that guy
raped her and then he [ __ ] murdered
him
yeah no but think about it david when
nothing
situations like that happen for example
when a woman
follows you know abusive or or
charges against her boyfriend or
whatever you know
husband i mean she calls the cops and
if in some cases they'll take the man
and they'll lock him up
and he's got to prove his innocence and
what happens if you have a job
you know it's the attorneys are not
cheap yeah you might lose your job
you're going to lose work so your life
is turned upside down over a lie
and now you got to go to court to prove
yourself that you're innocent over a lie
and all she gets is what a slap on a hen
and now you gotta start all over
so you know for a minute it's [ __ ] up
man that's crazy it is you know it
happens more than most people think
that's what i talk about
and i'm not again i mean any man that
hits puts a hand on a woman or just
abuse any kind of abuse of you know i
have a mother and sister
and daughter you know i don't go for
none of that but it needs to be
the same way for women that lie on a man
yeah the same thing needs to happen to a
woman when it does happen to a man
i think because also too uh from a
perspective that i've gotten before from
somebody else is that
i think a lot of guys feel they don't
talk up about it because they feel
masculine thank you
thank you thank you thank you that's
exactly what i was going to go to
you know we're guys you know we you know
we don't we don't sit around talking oh
man you don't even know
what happened yo my girlfriend [ __ ] me
oh that's not going to get up
but it's just what jesus said yeah he's
the man and you know she's
a manhood is the is that man you know
this is going to think of a man i told
my dad with my situation my dad was like
my dad was like
i mean did she like the family she was
like but did she like hurt you and i'm
like
dad she put her hands on me
but that's the thing that i i didn't you
know it happens man
you know man when men don't speak it
just gets
thrown in the under under the you know
yeah i mean i definitely
it needs to be brought up and that's
what i talk about when i do speeches
and i've done a sp i did a speech in
london and i tell you what man
it was all men and these guys i had guys
standing up clapping and after the
speech
i had guys in tears coming up to me it's
like man you had just changed my life
because
they don't even know they're in that
situation until you start talking right
they started talking
yeah and then you're like you brought it
out of me man
i'm gonna you know i'm not gonna let
this keep going yeah like for me to like
my
like in my household because i think
like my we grew up in a very volatile
household right like you know my parents
used to fight a lot like
angry [ __ ] fighting breaking [ __ ] in
the house like for me i hate that [ __ ]
and i i saw it like in
i i get a transfer of that like so when
i used to get angry when i was younger
i used to break [ __ ] all the time
because i used to see that my parents do
that [ __ ] as a kid
so in you know from here on out i'm
trying to correct this behavior of my
further
in my new relationships now it's still
hard i mean obviously i don't get
physical but i'll break my own [ __ ]
right which i'm trying not to do
when i get really angry um but i did
have a uh
one girlfriend that you know i kind of
defined these lines i was like listen
when you
we can play fight you know play fighting
whatever that's cool right but when
you're actually angry don't ever put
your hands on me because now it's a
little different right
now it's like you're hitting me to hurt
me yeah you know and
you know it got to the point where i had
to cut sit down and have a conversation
with this girl and i said hey you know i
play fight that's fine that's what we do
like korean people we like playing five
and that's just how we are right i was
like but the moment you touch me and
you're angry i was like
there's no conversation i get up i don't
speak to you ever again
i was like that's it yeah because i
can't handle that right because you
can't just start wailing on me because
oh i'm the weak
girl but i'm over here i'm getting
kicked upside the head and you know
because you think that you're the weak
girl and it's okay yeah you can't
put your hands on me because mind you if
it was the other way around i was angry
i just slapped you upside your head
what am i now you know what i mean and i
said like for me
and it's so interesting like when i look
back at it now it's like that was the
reason i told my i can't do that you
can't put your hands on me
and then i'm just supposed to be smile
about it you know after you just kick me
in my stomach and you know
you slapped me upside my head because if
it was the other way around i'd be in
jail like that oh yeah
retaliation that's it you're done yeah
you know to put it
in perspective david look let me tell
you a little fact here
uh shelters for women you know that that
are being abused or this
woman's shelter in particular there's
over
2000 or 3 000 in the old united states
shelter for men
two wow damn that's
crazy so if a man needs help
that because he's in a situation you
gotta head to wyoming
right now go to kanye's crib i know
that's what you gotta do you know you
gotta go to a puritan state
yeah that gives you perspective of what
society thinks about
men that are abused that's nuts and it's
interesting because that perspective is
so interesting because
um it's like what what can a guy do when
a girl gets hyper physical
like you just got to sit there and just
get socked in the face yeah you know and
you know i think a lot of guys
perspectively they go
you could just hold them down i was like
but you hold somebody down they get
bruised on their arm
or this and that you're telling me she
used that i mean she has she scratched
herself she had all kind of
bruce he took she would take all kind of
do all kind of bruises you know
scratches
and then take pictures and then use them
as evidence against me
and she just had like this mental lock
yeah she was she was she what she tried
so much
she had a whole game plan
that nothing that was part of the
divorce there's nothing worse so you
know what
damn it let's go to the she didn't know
god blessed you with patience
yes [ __ ] insane yeah she's like
okay
let's pull the murder case the murder
you know murder for her that's so nuts
that you are such a patient human being
that she had to just murder you
yeah that is crazy is that going to boil
down to she's like you know what this
guy right here i pulled
every [ __ ] trick in the book and
nothing is working so i just have to
kill him i admire his patience man i'll
be trying to look like y'all
your patience was good nah man this guy
i actually don't
like i kind of have a little short fuse
i still i don't really like
you know i'm more like passionate in my
voice where i'll like kind of like i'll
i'll go up an octave but like yeah this
guy he just stays calm bro like he'll
literally just like up
like he blows up like even even just off
of yesterday he already forgot about it
all day i've been looking at this fight
looking at the tape look at that looking
at the tape looking at the tape
and my dad's just like son just stop
looking at it why don't you just stop
watching it
no but she didn't come at one time it
was it was this one was that was
you know when you got to the point where
you know that's enough
you know she was talking junk about my
daughter mia
just you know just oh she tried to get t
yeah she was
good and that was the one you know when
she started messing with my kids
you know especially my daughter well she
pushed that button and got me
pissed and so i walked up the stairs
through my room
and man i just couldn't take it the door
was closed and you know it's one of
those doors that just oh hey
just unlock it yeah i just i feel like
oh you know this is not good
i just put my hand through it yeah and i
you know put a hole in the door
and i was like oh okay that's a good one
let me see picture
yeah 9-1-1 he's violent and the police
came
and they got me on that one they said
that you know i had to leave the home
and
when i told them the story they were
like well somebody has to leave at home
and she said we're the kids
so you're gonna have to go that's crazy
you know
that's not she's just trying to but you
see what i'm talking about you into it
that's crazy
you see one time i mean manipulation
mental you know and physically and
everything
but let's turn everything around let's
put me in the position where i was doing
all that
i would have been locked up a long time
ago just so i'm petty though i would
have keyed her car i would have slashed
the tires
i would have done this whole
investigation like babe we got to find
out who did this
you know i would rob our own house like
you know somebody keeps robbing what
kind of person is this that she knows
what i do with kids especially with a
non-profit that i'm helping the
community with kids that at risk
and she goes and tells the parents of
the kids that i'm embezzling money that
i'm not what you think that
what they think that i am that i'm gonna
have alcoholic at home and i'm an
abusive them
and that's crazy you went through so
much i can't even imagine
i got it what's this book called i
walked i walked in my own grave a true
crime story
i'm about to read the [ __ ] out of this
that is
nuts yup you can cop it on amazon i
walked on my own grave it was it was
sold out for a little bit
they restocked them yeah we're stuck
it's coming in it's coming out in
espanol
in december yeah wow dude
that's so [ __ ] nice i did not expect
this at all yeah man
you downplayed it quite well my friend
this is nuts i get i
i guess i guess for me you know i've
i've been talking about it a lot and and
um you know i also i feel like i just
watched the documentary right now
like
people read it i have people that have
read it and they come up to me
they'll find me wherever they see me
whatever and giving me hugs like man you
need a hug man you just
gotta just hug him god
though like were you i think i grew up
like that i was you know and then when i
asked them the same thing you know when
i box people always tell me like man it
was absolutely
calm to meet him how can you be a boxer
and then when they saw me in the ring
like oh
damn hold on well you get that friend
you know is
you know i can change you know i'm a
fighter i can fight yeah but
i know i just i'm a cool down the earth
i don't
nothing a lot you know other than
something happened to my kids and you
know
protecting my family that's different
you know but hey i don't look for
trouble
but patrolling looks for me i have to
depend on it i can't i can handle myself
but for what man you know i just just
just be cool respect people people
respect your back
wow yeah i can't even imagine like
there's so much stuff that happened
within your life i'm trying to collect
these pieces together
and i just put myself in your shoes and
for some reason i see the person not not
mario but let's say this woman was with
me
she would be dead
[Laughter]
she would be this she would be dead yeah
i mean that's all i could think or i
would just disappear in a hot second but
once again like when you're
kind of stuck in an abusive relationship
you don't see the chaos right you're
just dealing with the day-to-day things
and next thing you know you're trapped
it's a week then it's a month then it's
a year then it's two years
you know that's [ __ ] there was so
much it was fine finances
you know everything man did you know
your impossible's going through all this
no that's what i'm saying nobody knew
when he called me
i didn't know what was happening and
then when he when he told me to sit down
again i thought somebody died in the
family but he gave me everything and i
was like
well he was like yeah that's why you
haven't heard from me like i had to be
in this hotel and i couldn't contact
anybody
excuse me and nobody knew about it his
family his mom
his job like everybody was like why like
where's he at nobody you know i was
taken out of the grid
yeah when they started putting like the
makeup on you did they did they lighten
your skin up too to make sure like your
blood was draining no it was just
you know this was the picture it was
this is one of those things
they did that youtube thing and they
were like
uh when i couldn't believe it i was like
yo man she's not gonna fall for this
but apparently you know well obviously
she did but it was just one of those
pictures that
well got him yeah she's he was something
else man
but and that's her huh yeah yeah
and that's when you know a lot of people
when you know when they do these
documentaries about me
you know you know shows like i've been
on crime shows a lot of the main crime
shows
even the producers the producers are
like
wow this is this is this is incredible
it's like a hollywood movie man
i can't believe her daughter didn't go
to jail either because yeah she would
they couldn't find anything on
you know i guess when they when they
investigated her it was it was just
nothing they can fight on her man [ __ ]
those kids dude i'm sorry man
and they're to this day they're legally
in this country
her mother and her two kids are legally
in this country because of me
and i can't file anything on them
because their american citizens
and their mothers in american cities
they're all still american citizens
because of me wow
that is nuts yeah and she's still in
there for what the next one with 15
years well she's been up for parole the
last three years and
then she's been i'd be having to write
letters and
and everything but yeah she's been up
for parole for the last three years but
she's been denied
no so wow but she took it you know
her attorneys they knew that she has
the evidence against it was so much
so they said no we just better take this
plea because if you go to trial you're
gonna get life
lady of course she's over here doing the
harlem shake when she found out that you
died like
she pretty much damned herself once they
show the jury that picture you're done
you know they're like oh hell no there's
no emotional people i live in a very
you know upper middle class mostly white
old people
they're like oh hey every picture i see
it's like she's just smiling and
it just looks like she's like i got me
one wow
she was good when she thought she was
good it's so eerie when her mom
just whispered that in your ear like
she's your problem now it's like
look that's that's my my dad's parents
in the courthouse yeah watching the
emotional thing and look at my sister
and it was a packed part you know but
didn't hurt poor thing let me let me let
me finish up with this little bit right
the report after like the the where
was that at where they got me i had the
little interview oh that was in uh
in houston no i'm saying like in the
courthouse or something yeah
yeah but let me tell you what happened
that's when she got sentenced
and that's my attorney we're all it was
a packed
court you know all the newscasts and all
the news you know there all the
different news
media was there and uh
the da's asked me prior to the you know
her sentences
you know you can do a speech and but
they gave me the grounds you know i
could say i cannot say
so i said okay you know i just prepared
a little speech so i got on there
after she was sentenced not one that she
ever looked at me not even
not once yeah pack you know imagine this
is a packed courtroom with everybody
and so when i got up there i said uh
i told you know what uh lulu
everybody in this courtroom has made
mistakes there's not one perfect person
in this room
i forgive you for what you did and i can
hear this
what yeah it was like a
yeah everybody's like what did you just
say he's like this man is not human yeah
and so i you know but let me tell you
why i i did that
i get told you know i forgive you for
what you did to me
you know but i won't forget
now you got to pay the consequences
because that's how it is
now um when you live with this this
bottled up you know i live when the
whole time she was locked up
i had so much anger you know you know
that bottled up yeah yeah
and i'm not that you know you already
know you can see from my demeanor i'm
not that type of person but i had
developed so much anger inside of me
i mean i i was thinking retaliation i
was thinking about her kids if i see him
in the streets i was thinking about
everything i was thinking this just bad
bad bad thoughts were going through my
head to the point where
i had a friend that had guns you know
collect a gun collector basically
yeah he let me have you borrow one of
his shotguns
i had a loaded 40 millimeter in my
kitchen and another
nine millimeter loaded in my car and
that's how i spend every day
i slept with a loaded shotgun next to me
wow and that's how i slept so i had to
live like that
so when i sat there in front of that
courtroom
and forgave her it was like
all that hair is just and i was able to
release everything and it's like it was
just
release of all that anger that's
interesting i've said this multiple
times before like
forgiveness is never for the other
person it's for yourself yeah exactly
and it's like
it heals you exactly what it did i mean
i would never forget but
that moment right there that what i did
he was like
i'm done with you i'm done now you got
to pay the consequences for what you did
you know damn i'm always picturing
myself like i did you you're an
interesting man because i would have
stood up there i was like lulu let me
tell you something
i hope somebody gets inside your sweet
ass every [ __ ] day
all those moves that i touch in the ring
you know you learned you're gonna
be using them i hope you got that one
two three down pat cause people are
gonna
be beating your ass for the rest of your
life yeah oh my god that's
insane hey look and this is this is how
crazy i think if i tell you this chris
this lady this this one lady hit me up
on facebook
on facebook yeah she hit me up on
facebook and send me a message
hi mr sosa this is such and such uh this
is why she was still locked up in
at the county you know prior to getting
sentenced
and she goes my name is such and such i
was uh in the same jail cell with your
ex-wife where you are with your wife
maria
i'm like what she goes uh
i just wanted you know because she said
that she was sitting there she told her
a little story what she was in there for
uh and then she said but uh she's trying
to show somebody
she said she said you know but she
wasn't interested
it was like she was doing what you know
lulu in there
after after i came out now that i really
know what's going on
we used to ask you what she was in there
for but she would never say
she would never say what she was in
there nobody knew what she was in there
for
it was always but one thing that i
noticed that she became
a trustee real quick you know like she
started everybody started you know the
the the officers and
and the way he called the people the
ceos they all you know kind of
you know gravitated to her but she
started manipulating these people in
there
damn she's so good yeah she was a
trustee in no time she said
wow but nobody knew no but nobody that
was in like like i should get that
yeah nobody knew how and she was always
damn she is the devil
that is crazy now that i'm out here and
i see what the story is
now i understand what she was like that
that is [ __ ]
nuts read the book you'll see oh i'm
buying that book tonight on
amazon yeah oh my god it's crazy because
i feel like i just watched the doc
like it's in my head right now yeah bro
but there's like so many important
things
to the puzzle bro yeah like i got i want
to read this book so [ __ ] bad now
yeah
holy [ __ ] and it's a it's a good read
bro it's it's quick
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't just learn
pages like 168 but the thing is like
give my 68 bucks no but it's like
because you know when i read a book i
wanted to know when you when you finish
a chapter like oh [ __ ] i can't put it
down let me go to the next one like a
documentary like me yeah
that's that's how i wrote it you know
where where you can just oh hell no i
gotta finish that's the one is people
like
dammit i couldn't put your book down
here like i read it in one day yeah
i can put it down put it on you know one
two days i couldn't put it down
you know like i just pictured this kid
coming at you recording you just
telling you to get out of your own car
bro i wanted bro i had no idea what was
going on i want to whoop that boy there
so bad bro
messing with my dad like that and then i
know him like i know he's a [ __ ] bro
and i'm like bro why are you oh that
[ __ ] pissed me off dude
like taking advantage of somebody's
kindness yeah bro
and you're here legally yeah we had so
many conversations you know i'm trying
to be a father figure too young man
and say man you know how many people
come here from mexico undocumented
i mean crossing the river i mean just
living
dirt poor trying to make it day to day
to make it to where you're at and you'd
have none of that
none of that you came in here and you
have everything you have a home you have
you have everything you have a beautiful
yeah everything these people fight for
to get here
you have because of me yeah and i'm you
know
and and then you're gonna be like that
towards me yeah
that's nuts man you know like that is so
[ __ ] crazy i'm just
i mean what's that i'm not trying to
figure out what this loser's doing now
like it's like what are you doing you
[ __ ] loser
no idea bro no idea but
wow i can't believe her mom was all in
it too like recording and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] that lady as soon as he pulled
that phone out they were like oh
[ __ ] the phone they walked it's just
like they went but then i had
then when the cops came and i said well
don't show you the whole
they say oh no they just show me and
then because he actually edited it right
there on the spot yeah
and they were like we'll talk him didn't
say no tell him to show you the whole
video
hey but whenever she went to whenever
because my dad ended up staying with his
mom
during like the whole court thing and
all this stuff and whenever
they said you know you know my dad can
go back to his house
he went back to his house and my dad was
there with cops too to like
you know escort uh escort him there when
he got there
my mama my uh his his ex-wife
lulu had all of the family staying in
the house
everybody was living there this is what
happened you know when she got arrested
you know her family from mexico her
sister
the nut she had come with her husband
and her grand her kids
so they showed up and you know i wasn't
there because i haven't i wasn't able to
get back in my house yet
so they came to my house and there was
like that was my house was like a hotel
i've been like hey time to get the [ __ ]
out but this is what happened
so i had a uh you know because i before
that she was able to get me out of the
house you know
legally so my attorney was able to go to
court
and get it in writing that you know the
papers where i can move back
yeah you know i got legal in my house so
i was like
me it was another thing that happened me
mundo my uncle
and mitchell was there and my
brother-in-law we all got you know had
some shotguns and we were all loaded up
yeah and here's the door no this is
mundo sadie say mundo's always
we're going to go to home depot and get
new locks for your house front and back
we're going to go to your house and then
you're going to call uh
uh what's called people that lost
locksmith
and you're going to tell them you can't
get in your house and he's going to open
the door and we're going to change the
locks and we're going to wait for them
to come back and i was thinking what
everybody feel there no they're not
going to be there we're going to go
there late
so that's why we just got lucky we
showed up and exactly we i called the
locksmith and i showed him a driver's
license that you know my address and
there
okay you know he opened the house and
man we changed the locks and the
moon door and we changed those locks in
less than probably five minutes
front and back and they try to come in
they're like no no this is what happened
so sure enough we just waiting they
still my house they had computers
uh laptops with numbers with attorneys
and all these
they might you know luggage is all over
the house wow
and it was so my uncle we all had that
we're all loaded
so the daughter comes up to the knot to
the front door and knocks on the door
and my brother-in-law goes like this
here we go that's what it got yeah and
then he opened up the you know this the
shades
and he goes and sally goes what do you
want he goes oh we just come to get our
stuff i said nah you didn't come into
the house
wow that's when i was pissed and you
know when nobody's coming in here
so then they call them they ended up
calling the cops big solo
yes i was there but now but you know i
was there they called the cops
and uh and then uh i called my attorney
to see what you know
what we're going to do and then you know
the cobb was closing man i know what
happened on you i know your case and
everything
let's just put the guns away for now for
just to be safe yeah put all the guns
away
let me talk to you guys and then he
talked to me he talked to my attorney
and my attorney said well tell you what
ramon just calm down are you pissed
just calm down right now let's just let
the people that are came from out of
town
get their luggages and the young lady
the daughter
you know the son was in that little
[ __ ] he didn't show up yeah he you know
of course he didn't show up
he didn't want that smoke so he said the
young lady and her
and the grandmother to come in and get
one change of clothes
and i told mitchell my son said mitchell
i want you when they come in one at a
time i want you to record
everything they're doing yeah and the
cop you know it was the cop was there to
say no this is how we're gonna do it one
one of them's gonna come in at a time
you guys just stand back put all the
guns away this is what they they just
want to get their taxes [ __ ]
and we get down in texas
at this time they didn't know that mundo
was on my side he didn't know that
was the one that yeah put all this
together bro you should have seen the
look on her ground on her mother's face
when she walked in and she saw mundo
just wow
wow she was like holy [ __ ]
that her mom's a piece of [ __ ] too huh
yeah look at that
you know what shout out to texas because
that is dope actually would not happen
in california man
like texas is sounding extra nice to me
right now like
extra nice the cops could come he's like
he used to have your guns just put it
away for now
he said that's what i said yeah you just
put them away you know we don't need any
trouble just
yeah that is nuts man i would have just
like yeah you could i'll pick out the
clothes it's going to be the ugliest
[ __ ] so you're going to wear this
spongebob t-shirt and you about to wear
these [ __ ] pants
with the ass is cut out of it enjoy and
dress shoes
and dress shoes the brother-in-law her
brother-in-law he tried to be slick
because i stayed upstairs mitchell was
the one walking my older son was walking
behind him and the cop
recorded him so this fool comes down
like i didn't notice he comes with one
of those little uh
we had one of those little uh bags for
the you know for the uh for the bank
the bank bags they have one of those
upstairs and this fool comes down with
one of the bank bags
and i'm like bro what the [ __ ] what are
you doing with that who told you to take
that he was like
like you didn't see this oh you trying
to play real quick
i'm sleepwalking because i thought i was
sleeping
yeah he was like he was like what what's
this
what that's my [ __ ]
you know i said put it down yeah i said
put it down i was talking like [ __ ] put
the [ __ ] down
yeah well this and the couple was what
was going on said no man
what's he doing with my mom that's my
bank back for my business yeah
oh okay with the copy like get the [ __ ]
out of here
of course
you know man you better shut the [ __ ] up
and put the bank back down no man
you just say chassis
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god this is literally the craziest
[ __ ] story i've ever heard in my life
i can't believe
you still have your sanity about you
yeah this is
life's look right that is nuts to me
yeah these people are such characters
like human beings are so
odd like i always tell people when you
hear peop when
people who live in very small bubbles
they never get to hear these type of
things right so they
they think that every person that they
meet is going to be a great human being
right they literally see life through
this small [ __ ] lens
and sometimes too like arguably when i
meet people they're like they think i'm
very conscious not that i'm cautious
i just group around a lot of shitty
people like people who are
so good at being likable but a likable
doesn't mean you're a good person
they're just
very very [ __ ] good at manipulating
people yeah exactly
yeah and i [ __ ] hate that that's what
she is so she was exactly what she was
i mean she was the type of girl or lady
that
she knows she looked good because she
worked out she's beautiful her job her
job was just to look
good she worked out from the morning to
the evening yeah and then she loved to
dress nice and everything and this is
how she got you or to anybody
if you went shopping with her to the
mall you know one of the ladies that was
on
one of those shows even said i hated
going to you know shopping with her
because
anything that i said i like she would
buy for me anything i mean she literally
and she and we had motorcycles she
didn't
she had a harley she would go to places
and somebody said oh i like that jacket
she would literally take it off
here you can have it here you can have
it oh no this bell you can have him
what the [ __ ] you got nice teeth don't
worry about this
i don't need this one
she wanted something back when she
wanted something back you wouldn't
understand why
i remember that oh tenfold that's what
she did that's what i oh
man yours i tell kids this all the time
nobody gives [ __ ] to you in this world
for nothing
overly generous people that you just
meet off the job i'm not people
i'm not talking about people that you
create rapport with right like the
people who are like family yeah
that's different they'll give the
clothes off the back for you right the
people that you just meet that do that
be
very very [ __ ] conscious i've had so
many people that i know personal friends
of mine right that i've worn and i've
seen they get [ __ ] over so bad right
and in their mind they're like well i
don't understand how this happened i
thought we were good friends just like
no no no no no
you took from them and they wanted
something oh yeah
and you forgot that you got something
you thought you got something for free
but you did not
whether it was like a relationship like
some some dudes would like
be extra sweet to a [ __ ] girl right
and like oh this guy is just being nice
i mean is he really or does he want
something what does he want
you know and the other way i've seen
like i know of a personal friend that
got [ __ ] me too
like in this industry from a very
powerful person
and it was uh he's a male and the other
person was a female
and i had a conversation with him
uh late at night it was when we went to
a bar and i said the same phrase
nobody gives you that much without
asking for something in return
and you know in his mind he's like no
we're being nice and i was like listen
you know what you're taking from this
person all right and i was like right
now you're taking a lot
this person is going to ask something
back from you like sure enough
and sure enough what it was was a
relationship they didn't get it and then
his life kind of spiraled after that
and he's like he was mad at and i was
like well
you know [ __ ] that person but also too
you weren't smart about your [ __ ]
everybody told you that you were taking
too much from this person
and that person got nothing from your
relationship well it was time to pay up
and you didn't do it so now this person
feels like they got gypped
so it's it's weird like people
being able to really break down a human
being is a difficult difficult thing
like it's hard right you need life
experience you need experiences like
this sometimes to be like
oh now i'm more cautious about this [ __ ]
that's why i get scared sometimes for
these kids that just stay in a room and
they don't talk to people
they get [ __ ] they're the first peop to
get [ __ ] over because they haven't had
enough human interaction they can't
pick up on small little behaviors like
oh this person is a little fake ass
this person over here wants something
for me it's because they never met
people like right
right your situation that was unique you
actually met a psychopath
what exactly was saying like so good at
what she does
in saying that she [ __ ] fooled a
whole prison how how was that
how's it even possible oh
it's like get back into your cell inmate
you're sure
and look and if the same lady the same
letter she manipulated with that
later on she came after all this
happened she came out opened up to me
and she said that she said lulu had
opened up to her about
the situation with my car with my
vehicle then she said
i told her but how come you didn't tell
me i mean you shouldn't have said no
because
i just don't have to get in between and
then we were very good friends and
and believe it or not i was believing
everything she was saying about you
obviously i'm wrong but i was believing
everything oh my god
check this out and this is another thing
that blew my mind she told me that
luna had told her that she used to run a
brothel
in mexico she was a big momma
man the [ __ ] and i had no idea
and i'm like because you know she's lose
to me she was an executive
uh secretary for ford corporation in
mexico city
yeah and she's you know that's what she
did her driving you know it was true
but on the side she was also she was a
masseuse
she used to own a massage parlor you
know like she owned a massage place you
know whatever
and i said dan don't go because she used
to give you some good massage like then
she died she knows what she's doing she
went to school she showed me her degree
whatever i mean
certificate and i thought was all legit
and then this lady told me
that she had a brothel that she had
ladies that worked for her
what in the [ __ ] i never knew that one
let me tell you this girl can survive
like no matter what she's gonna survive
like she's a succubus she'll steal your
soul she'll steal
everything from you yeah wow so she
probably have a book when she comes out
my side yeah my side of the story a
walk-through remote
like the difference is i got video
footage [ __ ] what are you talking about
[ __ ] demon that's a pure demon
oh my god i might well what kind of
perspective is that
charm and sophisticated you know
mental wow she was very i saw a photo i
was like no she's very pretty
yeah and she knew it too she would walk
into a room and she would get mad at
people then pay attention to her
oh [ __ ] and she saw somebody that looked
better than her she's like look at that
[ __ ] with them fake titties
oh my god yeah look at that fake [ __ ]
that's a fake ass don't believe that
that's
if i look like what do you think that
ass is fake i was like it's fantastic
and then there's another one she used
all the time i'm jealous of the wind
that touches you
what in the hell damn she be making you
feel special
this [ __ ] was genuine yeah
she was poetic damn that [ __ ] made me
feel good about myself
she said i'm jealous of the wind that
touches you get out of here
go home and do that on your on your
fiance yeah
i'm jealous of the touch of the wind
that wait huh yeah mario don't even fall
for that she'll love me like
you drunk get the [ __ ] away from me i'm
like that's my lady
chris heard what they wrote a song about
me too oh no
no no no all right
all right you guys we're closing now
that's genius podcast i'll do it for you
before we wrap this up i mean that story
was amazing before let me plug that back
please if you get a chance
uh it's a great book um i went through a
lot
but i'm grateful that people that have
read my book
and people that all the shows that i've
been on and the podcast
uh what i want people to get from this
is to learn from what happened to me
to please understand that listening to
men
and men especially that are listening to
this show or this podcast
please and if you're going through some
kind of relationship where you're the
the victim of domestic abuse just you
know remember you're not alone
you're not alone it doesn't make you
less of a man it doesn't make you a
[ __ ]
i mean look at me i'm a next
professional fighter i'm fired i mean
trust me i will put my hands i mean
my hands i i'm not scared of any kind of
any man yeah but i would
never ever ever put a hand on a lady
yeah i respect them
but it got it has to go both ways yeah
so my hope is that um
you know if if i can help somebody if my
book helps somebody and if you know
somebody that's going through some
different
difficulties with a relationship as far
as domestic abuse
uh you know if we find some crazy ladies
like i'm married
you know you can learn from what
happened to me you know yeah remember
you're not alone
that is and one last thing you know take
it from me
you look at like a life differently when
you have walked on your own grave
yeah that's nuts yeah
you can uh you can cop my dad's book on
amazon i walked on my own grave
and uh um you could uh you could find me
in my dad's book
i walked in my own grave i guess there's
some uh cameos in there some photos and
stuff and um
it's something it gets kinky but it gets
uh it's real it's rough it's wrong
the message
about what happened to me and then
that's how i want people to understand
that it can happen to you like this
raw you know i like don't think like i
you know
tries to read the book she's like um why
does the book jump from 27 to 30.
why this page is stuck i was like hey
hey don't worry about that
that's how it came that's how i came
hey man but yeah no y'all can catch me
on on all platforms at christino sosa
c-r-i-s-t-i-n-o
uh your followers know uh know me so
they they they know how to do their
research all right we got we gotta do
that plug man
damn dude you never even told your other
story huh wait
one day what story your story the story
the
story no i have that's how they found me
but did you go and you didn't go into
the specifics oh i did that on my
podcast
yeah maybe you didn't even yeah for
another another one yeah
you can catch it in your spring every
thursdays and sundays and we will catch
you all next time
peace peace